okay so the way that you sense or feel  pain is your body has a pain pathway  which is essentially a series of nerves  and these nerves have tiny little pores  or channels that regulate the movement  of sodium and potassium ions and by  regulating the movement of ions through  the membranes of these nerve fibers you  can create an electrical signal so your  pain pathway takes painful information  from your environment like a scorpion  sting or being burned or cutting  yourself and that information is then  turned into electrical signals which  travel along your nerves towards your  spinal cord and then from the spinal  cord those electrical signals are sent  to your brain where that information is  processed and you actually feel the  sensation of pain  you